PROFESSOR: All right.
So that concludes the chapter,
a big chapter in this course.
It concludes time-dependent
perturbation theory.
The whole course is
largely organized
with approximation methods.
We have done time-independent
perturbation theory.
We applied it to the
hydrogen atom in detail.
Then we did WKB, which is
slowly varying things in space.
Then we did time-dependent
perturbation theory.
It had many parts to it.
It had Fermi's
golden rule, atoms.
It had just
transitions in general.
The next step would be
adiabatic approximation,
which is time-dependent
changes but slow.
This is the time analog of WKB.
We're going to take
a little break.
And for half a lecture
today and the full lecture
next time, we're
going to do particles
in electromagnetic fields.
That's an important subject.
It will involve Landau
levels and things
that you always hear about.
And it will be useful for
some of the things we've done.
We've had a little exposure
to it with the Pauli equation.
You may remember the Dirac
and Pauli equation that
had this electromagnetic field.
So now we're going
to take seriously
the electromagnetic fields
and study how they interact
with quantum mechanics.
And there's a lot of very
interesting and beautiful ideas
having to do with
gauge invariance
and why potentials
are important.
Charged particles in
electromagnetic fields.
So charged particles
in EM fields.
So what is our useful problem?
You have a particle with
mass m, now charge q.
And finally, there's an electric
field and a magnetic field.
And there's going to be
interactions between them.
So there's E and B.
And you've gone through
this transition.
Probably, you've been told
in electromagnetism something
along these lines.
There is this E and B fields.
And those are the
physical fields.
These are the things that do
stuff on charges and particles.
And there is this mathematical
entities that can help you,
which are potentials,
that allow you
to rewrite these fields in
terms of these quantities,
potentials.
And they're practical
to solve the equation.
But the potentials are less
physical than the fields,
because the potentials
are ambiguous.
You can change the
value of the potential
without changing
the electric field.
You can do things like that.
Well, that is somewhat
misleading, put charitably.
It's a pretty wrong
viewpoint, actually.
As we will discover
and understand here,
the potentials are really more
important than the fields.
Quantum mechanics couples
to the potentials.
And as an afterthought,
if couples to the fields,
because it couples
to the potentials.
But even the definition of
an electromagnetic field,
at the end of the
day-- nowadays,
we really understand it as
a definition of potentials.
And I'll try to explain that.
This is pretty important if
you try to describe anything
that has topological content.
Most of the times, if
you're considering open
space, open Minkowsky space,
it doesn't make much difference
whether you take the electric
and magnetic field to be
fundamental or the potentials.
But as soon as you consider
anything topological,
a sample that lifts on a
toroidal surface, that's
a topological
space, then, if you
don't think about
potentials, you
could be absolutely
wrong, completely wrong.
Or if you have an
extra dimension, and in
many theories of physics, you
could have extra dimensions--
and you think about the
electric and magnetic fields
then, if you don't
think of potentials,
you can be quite wrong.
So let's explain
what's happening
with these potentials.
Basically, it all
starts from the idea
that you have a Maxwell's
equation del dot B equal 0.
And this is solved,
it is said, by setting
B equal to the curl
of A. And indeed,
if B is equal to the curl of
A, this equation is satisfied.
The other equation that is
relevant is this Faraday's
law, which if B is already curl
of A, you have that curl of E
plus 1 over C da/dt
is equal to 0.
You see, I substitute
B here equal curl of A.
I commute the order of
derivatives, the dt the curl.
And this gives me this equation.
From this equation, we say
that anything that has 0 curl
is the gradient of something.
And therefore, we say that
E plus the 1 over c da/dt
is the gradient
of phi, from where
we find the second
equation, which
says that E can be obtained
as minus the gradient of phi
minus 1 over c da/dt.
I hope I have it right.
Yes.
So this is the origin
of the potentials.
You've seen that.
That's how they
explain, probably,
to you why you have potentials.
And indeed, this
is so far so good.
But now, there is a freedom
with this potentials which are
called gauge transformations.
So what are the gauge
transformations?
It's the possibility of changing
the potentials without changing
the electromagnetic fields.
So for example, since the curl
of the grad of anything is 0--
it's almost like
curl cross curl is 0.
This is the curl of the
grad of anything is 0.
You can change A
into a different A
that we'll call A prime,
given by A plus gradient
of a function lambda.
And this will not change the
value of the magnetic field B,
because if you calculate
the magnetic field B,
the new magnetic field
associated to the new vector
potential is equal
to curl of A prime.
But that's equal to
curl of A. And that's
equal to the old B due to the
old magnetic vector potential.
So the vector potential has
changed, but B the not change.
On the other hand, if you
change the vector potential
by something like this,
now it can affect the E.
But if simultaneously you change
phi, E will be left unchanged.
So what should you do to phi?
So this is the first one for A.
If you want to keep
E unchanged, you
define phi prime equal to phi
minus 1 over c d lambda/dt.
And then when you
compute the new E,
you would do the gradient
of the new phi, which
will be the gradient
of the old phi,
but an extra term, which
would be plus 1 over C
d/dt of gradient of lambda.
And it will cancel
with the minus 1
over C d/dt of the
gradient of lambda.
So by changing A and phi in
this way, B and E are unchanged.
So I can summarize this
gauge invariance statement
by saying that the new electric
field due to due to phi
prime and A prime is equal to
the electric field due to phi
and A. And the magnetic
field new due to phi prime
and A prime is equal
to the magnetic field
due to phi and A.
This is lifted to a principal.
So we started describing
electromagnetic fields
with E and B. We can
describe them with A and phi.
And let's take that
seriously, because we'll
need it for quantum mechanics.
And we'll add now the extra
important physical assumption,
which is that phi
prime A prime is
really equivalent, physically
equivalent to phi A.
And an electromagnetic
field configuration,
as a mathematician will say,
is the equivalent classes
of potentials.
So you want to describe
an electromagnetic field?
I ask one of you.
And you tell me what is phi and
what is A. I ask somebody else,
they give me another
phi and another A.
And you say, they
look different.
But they may be the same.
They are the same if they
are related by some lambda.
I'll write it.
If there exists a lambda
such that they are gauge
transforms of each other.
So before you say, you tell me
what the E is and what B is,
and they have to agree.
And you say, that's preferable,
because if E and B are
the same, they agree.
That's it.
Why do we go through A and phi?
They don't have to agree.
And they can be the
same, because if they're
related with some lambda,
they are the same.
We seem to be going backwards
into a lot more complicated
situation.
But that's what we need.
And that's what the physics
tells you is really going on.
So some particular things that
are curious can happen now.
And they're very curious.
And there are examples.
And we'll see some
of those examples.
So curious effects.
1, suppose phi and A and
phi prime and A prime
give the same E and B. So
you and your peer editor
came up with some phi and A
and phi prime and A prime.
And they give the
same E and B. Are you
and your peer
editor on the hands
of the same electromagnetic
field configuration?
Maybe but not obvious.
In classical physics,
you would say, yes.
If they give you the same E
and B, these are equivalent.
No, now, you would
have to show that there
is some lambda so that they are
gauge equivalent to each other.
You see, the fact that they
are gauge equivalent guarantees
they give the same B and E. But
if they give the same B and E,
it may happen that you still
cannot find the lambda that
relates them, because what
you have to do is try to take
your friend's A and
your friend's phi,
then this is yours and yours,
and now you have to find
the lambda.
And you have to solve a
differential equation.
What if you can't
find the lambda?
They give the same E
and B, but they're not
gauge equivalent to each other.
That means that you have
different field configurations.
The fact that E
and B are the same
doesn't mean they are the
same electromagnetic fields.
And this can happen if you
have a little bit of topology.
So suppose A and this
give the same B field
but are not related by
a gauge transformation.
Then these are
inequivalent EM fields.
They could have different
quantum mechanics.
And we will see that.
So one example is what
people call Wilson loops.
Wilson loops correspond to some
closed curve in space that you
cannot contract.
Of course, in Minkowski
space, in this room,
I can contract anything.
But sometimes, if
you live on a torus
or your sample is on
a sphere or something,
you may not be able
to contract the curve.
Along that curve, you can
put a vector potential
that is pointing tangent
to the curve all the time.
And it's a constant, a
constant vector potential.
That constant vector potential
has 0 B and 0 electric field.
But if that constant is small
or that constant is big,
it's inequivalent.
You won't find the
gauge transformation
that transforms each other.
And therefore, those
would be configurations
of electromagnetic fields
that give you the same E and B
but are inequivalent.
So that's the first
curious effect.
There is another curious effect.
And quantum mechanics is
forcing you to do that.
That's the main thing.
So the second curious
effect is, given
an E and B that satisfy
Maxwell's equation,
are these allowed fields?
So somebody gives you an
E field and a B field.
And you say, OK,
I'm going to check
if these are possible physical
electric and magnetic fields.
And then you go and check
Maxwell's equations.
And Maxwell's
equations work out.
They're all satisfied.
You say, OK, this is good.
Those electric and
magnetic fields are fine.
Not so quick.
To be sure those electric
and magnetic fields are fine,
you should give me a phi
and an A that gives rise
to them, because fundamentally,
the electromagnetic fields are
A and phi.
And those you need anyway to
do quantum mechanics with it.
So if you have an
electromagnetic field and you
cannot do quantum mechanics with
it, you would be suspicious.
So you need to find phi and A.
Are these allowed?
Only if you can find a phi and
A. And sometimes that can fail.
On a torus again--
we've described in
this course as circle
as a line x identified with
x plus L. So here is L.
And you identify.
A torus can be done by
taking a piece of the plane
and identifying this line
with that and this line
with this line.
So you glue this,
form a cylinder,
and then you glue
the other ends.
On a torus, you can put a
constant magnetic field.
A constant magnetic fields
satisfies Maxwell's equations.
So you say, oh, so you can put
any constant magnetic field
in a torus.
Wrong.
The vector potential
has trouble existing.
And only for particular
values of the magnetic field,
there's a consistent
vector potential.
You get the quantization of
the flux of the magnetic field.
So that's another
example, an E and a B.
A constant magnetic
field on a torus
satisfies every Maxwell
equation you may want to do.
But still, it's not a valid
electromagnetic field,
because there's no A and
phi that give rise to it.
So those are our lessons in why
we need the vector potentials
to describe physics
in quantum mechanics,
electromagnetic physics.
And then let's write,
therefore, the Schrodinger
equation with the
electromagnetic fields.